[Music]
something that happens to you when you
leave this town far the way the easier
it all gets the me and I've left I
remember all of it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
to the losers we made an oath I swear if
it isn't dead if it ever comes back
we'll come back - we didn't stop we
can't let it happen again
[Music]
[Music]
for 27 years
I dreamt of you
[Music]
I'll miss you
[Music]
we need to finish
[Music]
it assumes us from the inside in so we
don't have a choice
you live
[Music]
yes help you I used to live here
won't you come in it's the least I can
do is it like you remember cleaner yeah
well you feel free to look around while
I get the water boiling your hair is
winter fire January embers
[Music]
there you go awesome music I do
apologize but that's so very hot here
this time of year it's fine but you feel
like you could just about die but you
know what they say about dairy hmm
no one who dies here ever really dies
but tell me how is it being back in
Derry it's got a strange strange oh my I
had some cookies in the oven before you
came Steve right there I shouldn't
impose I'm gonna no I insist
we photos are lovely mr. Kirsch are
these your family my father came to this
country with 14 dollars in his pocket
what did he do mrs. Kirsch my father
joined the circus
I was always daddy's little girl what
about you are you still his little girl
Beverly are you
[Music]
it's me and losers Club has officially
begun
[Music]
I wasn't doing this but you have to
stick together
[Music]
hello
[Music]